the true story of two idiots who got
rich off of selling weapons in a
scenario that's just way over their
heads nothing's gonna go wrong with this
at all at all war dogs some war dogs is
like I said a true story directed by the
director of The Hangover trilogy he was
one for three on that so let's see how
he does air movie stars Jonah Hill and
miles teller there were friends when
they were kids and then they run into
each other together and in Jonah Hill's
like hey I sell weapons for a living
come on in with me this miles teller has
a kid on the way now and he just moved
he's a massage therapist and he makes
[ __ ] money doing it is like it why not
why not nothing's gonna go bad and it
the things yeah it gets a little crazy
Jonah Hill's character let's start out
with this guy you knew from the trailer
he was gonna be the douche bag version
of the - but I will say he's great at
being like just a kind of a piece of
[ __ ] I say piece of [ __ ] in the sense
it's like he's entertaining as hell to
watch but I never hang out with the
dudes I really I just don't trust you
I'm just saying the scene in the trailer
he has the automatic ride ones you don't
shoot it in the air like he just sees
thinks he's so awesome I'll say guys
gonna annoy me in the movie that scene
whatever you want to say that scene is
rad that scene immediately made you
curious as to where this guy's coming
from he's like a little bus fire you
can't look away ever you want to see
more miles teller was great - he's a
good actor and he the movie focuses on
him more ease the average guy is the
everyday guy he's you he's me and miles
teller proves once again that that whole
fan four stick thing they just eat bad
call it happens to people [ __ ] people
make mistakes what really works as miles
teller and Jonah Hill's chemistry
together the two are a great duo this is
their a weird Odd Couple the corrupting
one the nice one who just kind of gets
in over his head it's classic you see
that [ __ ] all the time
Bradley Cooper was great in the scenes
he was in he's not in the movie much he
doesn't steal the show or anything but I
thought he was perfectly fine good
Bradley Cooper's character have been
played by a myriad of other people yeah
he could have but he wasn't Bradley
Cooper did a good job in the move - but
best of all the movies just interesting
it's fascinating that this whole
scenario actually happened built on
bricks and mortar laid out by the US
government where these guys could just
be like hey let's just make money do we
know what we're doing absolutely not but
we're going to do this we're going to
contribute to the war economy is it new
no Metal Gear Solid 4 baby
touched on that should do where the
movie falters a bit is in its pacing
it's a bit of a roller coaster so
there's a huge story to tell I totally
get that at a point I was like alright
it's slowing down now and it was really
cool at the beginning it's really cool
at the end in the middle there is this
downtime that you're like alright speed
it up guys speed it up because in the
end war dogs was entertaining it was
funny in parts it starts out really dark
you're like is this I know it's not
going to be a comedy but is it going to
have comedy and it does have comedy but
delivered in a way where it's just the
absurdity of this movie in this scenario
in this situational circumstance that
they're all in and Jonah Hill because
he's what can I say it's a prick but I
feel like a lot of people out there can
gravitate to this movie because we all
know what that's like all of us have had
those average jobs we want to make more
with our lives want to do more with our
lives want to make more money how do you
do it this it okay there was a time I
probably would have run guns to get out
of a shitty retail management job yeah
turns out there's a video website where
you can upload videos and talk about
movies so did that instead I'll say the
movie wasn't anything special but I was
entertained in it I will say war dogs is
a good time no alcohol required I guess
of war dogs have you seen it what did
you think about it what's the movie that
you love most it's based off of a true
story whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more